der schweizer unternehmer und diplomatie
sieg hat weit über 1000 chinesische
künstlerinnen und künstler in ihren
ateliers besucht mit ihnen diskutiert
tee getrunken und in rund 30 jahren eine
einzigartige sammlung von über 2000
werken zusammengetragen er gilt weltweit
als wichtigster sammler erforschen und
vermittler chinesischer gegenwartskunst
und kunst ist ein medium aber unisex
eigentliches forschungsprojekt ist china
herzig sie sind zu china gekommen wie
die jungfrau zum kind das ist so es war
mir nicht in die wiege gelegt ich habe
mich nie damit befasst und beruflich bin
ich dann ganz unvermittelt hinein
gestoßen worden
das war in einer zeit als man erst kurze
zeit gestorben war in den 70er jahren
und sie waren als manager für einen
schweizer industrieunternehmen nach
china gesandt worden wie hat sich das
abgespielt
wir wurden zunächst vom chinesischen
delegationen kontaktiert in der schweiz
und die haben uns dann eingeladen unsere
technologie in china zu präsentieren wir
haben die einladung angenommen dann
hingegangen eben kaum vorbereitet was
die kultur anbetrifft was den zustand
kinos damals anbetraf es gab ja auch
eine fast unüberwindliche schranke um
von außen nach innen in china zu
gelangen und trat so muss der hand heben
einfach hingehen und wie muss man sich
china vorstellen ende der 70er jahre
das hat mit dem heutigen china nichts
mehr gemein
es war ein anderer kontinent das heutige
china ist eine jedenfalls in den
städtischen gebieten sehr
ausdifferenzierten gesellschaft
damals war aber ein monolith das
straßenbild grau es gab 24 die uniformen
geschnitten waren grün grau blau
waren die einzigen farbe bilden die
frauen zu genau den zelten haarschnitt
und ja in dem sinne war es ein land das
von einer planwirtschaft damals noch
total beherrscht war es heißt man alle
sie sind nicht sofort dann mit kunst in
berührung gekommen nämlich an
nein ich habe zwar sehr früh weil ich ja
ein interesse am gegenwartskunst mit
brachte mich um diese szene kümmern
wollen sie hatte etwa mit meiner ankunft
in china bekommen nämlich in den ersten
tagen der öffnung von china davon beim
shopping kommentierten öffnung und so
wollte ich eigentlich diese
entwicklungen vom tag eins an mir
ansehen es war aber sehr sehr schwierig
und es wäre nicht statthaft gewesen in
den ersten tagen sich darin diese
beginnen die szene hineinzubegeben aber
die waren sich bewusst dass eine art
epochenwandel sich ganz in einem
frühstadium befand das waren wie
verleger und ich musste mich aber wie
gesagt jetzt auch den bewegen
ich war ständig beobachtet bewacht
begleitet konnte keinen schritt alleine
tun
es gab ja auch ein sprachproblem konnte
noch nicht genetisch und so wäre es
nicht möglich gewesen ein gespräch unter
vier augen mit dem man dann zu führen
und sich mit der zeitgenössischen kunst
zu befassen
damals war alles offiziell erwartet
unstatthaft es hätte das unterfangen den
weg in bälde ja in china war aufs spiel
gesetzt ich führte damals von der
westlichen seite her das erste
gemeinschafts unternehmen
ich wollte es zum modell machen hätte
ich mich derart exponiert dann wäre ich
gescheitert das konnte ich ja mein blick
auf das unternehmen schon mal nicht tun
einfach meine passion wegen
und ich hätte auch die künstler sehr
gefällt das heißt sie waren ja damals
von der ausbildung helfen von ihren
beruflichen hintergrund auch ein ein
neugieriger journalist sie waren ja
wirtschaftsjournalist und das heißt sie
mussten also ihre neugierde zuerst
einmal im zaum halten
das war so ich konnte mir jedenfalls
informationen nur über mittelsleute
beschaffen
foto soweit bis sie schon gab gespräche
das war zunächst mein zugang insel
gegenwartskunst und ich meine wir
beginnen mit dieser vergangenheit
einfach dafür um zu verstehen dass
dieses klima von damals ganz wenig noch
mit dem china von heute zu tun hat und
das ist dann hat das gefühl 100 jahre
her sind und nicht erst 30 oder 40 jahre
wir haben einen einspieler als einem
film den michael schindhelm über sie
gedreht hat wo man die eine kuratorin
des guggenheim museums in new york sid
die uns erklärt eigentlich was da an
kultureller gesellschaftlicher
revolution sich abgespielt hat china
dass man uns kurz anschauen
die grenzländer tiefe dollars diskutiert
aber völlig der musik 2009 in der lage
sein die von dem ins kriterien erstmals
fotos oder sogar als fahrzeugteile ganz
weniger vorlauf geräte und die große
gang ist es dein nach seinem weg nach
dem jahr 2000 an große der nationale
sammler wo beim ganze nachfolger fand
pixel sind unser plan
[Musik]
das war eine eine sequenz aus diesem
film und eigentlich begonnen zusammen
haben sie dann als schweizer botschafter
in der zweiten hälfte der 90er jahre und
wir haben sie gesehen im einstieg des
ein spieler als eine art pandabär hat
ist dass so etwas eine art von
diplomatischer verkleidung gewesen die
sie gebraucht haben um sich in dieses
milieu und in diese welt und sie sich
vielleicht auch sogar eine parallelwelt
zu begeben
nein es ist romantischer ich habe
gemeinsam mit dem künstler einen film
produziert einen kinofilm
der hat aber gefloppt in china und dafür
schuldet mir dieses porträt und er
selbst immer performance gemacht
gemeinsam mit einem panda dieser
aufgetreten
und so lag es für ihn nahe mich so zu
zeigen also nicht als aussterbende
gattung die man
muss aber wenn man sich dann auch
nochmals erleben dass sie zuerst als als
vertreter einer schweizer
industrieunternehmen sind china waren
dann als diplomat und nun beginnt sie
als diplomat sich in die ateliers zu
begeben
das ist nicht eine aktie diplomatische
freizeitbeschäftigung in einem klima das
künstler in dieser zeit
gegenwartskünstler kritische künstler ja
nicht nur als sonderling ist und danach
als eine art von gefährdungen angesehen
haben
es ist so ich musste mich quasi tagsüber
im offiziellen china bewegen und nacht
bin ich dann zwar auf in den untergrund
gegangen wo die künstler damals tätig
waren und das ist eigentlich irgendwie
gut gegangen man konnte sich auch sehr
viel freier bewegen in den 90er jahren
ich habe mich eigentlich dann völlig
frei gefühlt und diese neugierde auf das
was sie nicht kannten von china
wenn sie jetzt diese 30 jahre
zurückschauen hat können sie uns in
einem satz gibt es irgendeine
quintessenz von erfahrungen die sie
jetzt am schluss dieser sammlung woche
mit uns teilen könnten
es gibt keinen besseren spielern per
gesellschaftlichen entwicklung aus die
zeitgenössische kunst und ich denke wo
aus diese sammlung
man könnte 1000 bücher lesen
man würde nicht dorthin gelangen zu
diesem verständnis dass man als einem
ausgedehnten gang durch die sammlung
gewinnen kann
das heißt also eine stark ausgeprägte
visuelle auch wahrnehmung eines ein-
oder nonverbale waren im
untergesellschaft der einstieg ist
visuell aber was sich hinter dieser
oberfläche öffnet ist natürlich
materiellen und ist ohne ohne limite was
die sinnesorgane anbetrifft
die das visuelle ist die oberfläche aber
dahinter nehmen wir alles war
was wir immer wahrnehmen wollen oder
können ich habe ein das thema liegt das
liegt es nahe ein lauer zitat gefunden
das mir ein bisschen auf sie zu passen
scheint dass er die dinge wahrzunehmen
ist der keim der intelligenz es ist
ebenfalls der anfang in der analyse und
idealerweise kommt es dann zu
kompositionen so würde ich den satz
lesen sie sich weiterhin für vorstellen
das passt ja auch zu ihnen glaube ich
diese art von vervollständigung von von
reflexion von prozessen vermittlung von
prozessen zwischen diesen beiden
kulturen für mich persönlich war ein
schlüsselmoment die biennale in venedig
von 1999 als ich zum ersten mal mit
chinesischer gegenwartskunst in kontakt
kam
harald seemann hat diese legendäre
geniale kuratiert und im rahmen einer
ausstellung die aperto hieß öffnung
waren zum ersten mal von 19 chinesische
gegenwartskunst zu sehen und mir ist das
herz aufgegangen aber auch wirklich also
die sinne haben sich geöffnet und es ist
eine art von von euch vor ihr habe ich
glaube ich mitgenommen von dieser
biennale zu sehen dass die welt sich
öffnet und weitet das war 1999 zehn
jahre nach dem massaker auf dem platz
des heiligen friedens wo stand china zu
dieser zeit wie was ist da passiert in
diesen jahren nachgegangen und renal in
venedig zunächst waren nach 89 die
künstler wie gelähmt und haben
resigniert und über die 90er jahre haben
sich dann die gemüter wird geöffnet auch
eine politische öffnung zeichnet es sich
ab der freiheitsgrad der künstler
erhöhte sich plötzlich konnten sie als
dieser als ist ein semi untergekommen
jedenfalls in eine eingeschränkte
öffentlichkeit
treten plötzlich gab es magazine people
magazine coffee club und magazine und
die künstler die ganz wenige jahre zuvor
eben noch angefeindet wurden waren
plötzlich public vickers in dem sinne
hat sich damals eine sehr große öffnung
abgespielt und plötzlich bildete sich
ein markt heraus und er hat dann
unglaubliche zahl und produziert bis
dann der crash traum auch für die
chinesische kunst im jahr
07 08 auf den markt richtig noch zu
sprechen kommen vielleicht bleiben ja
noch ein bisschen bei dieser frage von
der kunst und der kritik die die die der
avantgardekunst so wie wir sie in europa
kennt seit 100 jahren in der band ist in
china ein verschobener zeitlicher
prozess und dass man gemerkt hat wir im
westen dank ihnen weil sie wesentlich
dazu beigetragen haben dass man 1999
schon chinesische gegenwartskunst im
westen hat sehen können dass man gemerkt
hat hier entwickelt sich so etwas wie
ein gesellschaftliches korrektiv zu dem
was man als bild von china zeigt mag das
etwas was die offizielle das offizielle
china bewusst wahrgenommen hat damals
es traut überhaupt erst ins bewusstsein
das offizielle china was dann eine
überrumpelung und die ja kann man so
sehen
zunächst bekämpfte das offizielle china
die gegenwartskunst
sie hat ja eigentlich nicht dem chinesen
paradigma von kunst entsprochen
das heißt schönheit harmonie gefallen
das westliche paradigma dem eben die
gegenwartskunst cristina folgte war ja
die das bestehende einzureißen und
völlig neu zu beginnen nicht eben das
bestehende weiterzuentwickeln und in dem
sinne war das völlig chinesisch aber
diese entwicklung eben vom
venedig 99 zb die hat dann dem
offiziellen china die augen geöffnet
dass sie ein prozess abläuft dass hier
ein publikum im westen
nach dieser art informationen über sucht
und dass dieser prozess ohne irgendein
zutun des offiziellen china abläuft in
dem sinne glaube ist eine bewusstwerdung
in klima und plötzlich hat sich das
offizielle china um die gegenwartskunst
jedenfalls und teile davon zu kümmern
bekommen für mich noch einmal diese art
von dekade zwischen 1989 es gibt dieses
berühmte foto dieses mannes mit den
einkaufstüten vor den vor den panzern
und das ist so eine ikone dieser dieser
zeit und eines einen einer einer politik
in china die bei uns unverständnis
auslöst und dann so klang der den
goldenen löwen gewinnt und wo sehen sie
da schnittmengen soll ich sagen in
diesem verständnis dass eine tradition
ein verhalten das individuum die
gesellschaft sich trifft
ich würde das vielleicht brennen von
dieser vermeintlichen akzeptanz der
gegenwartskunst
beim offiziellen klien ich denke die
dinge so wie sie beschrieben haben die
haben sich in der gesellschaft
abgespielt die sich rasend schnell
verändert hat wie wo keine zuvor in der
menschlichen geschichte
man muss sich auch die ideologischen
klimmzüge vorstellen durch die ein
individuum gehen musste sagen wir es
wäre so sehr alt wie ich das bin dann
musste man ja schon etwas 67 dramatische
wendungen ideologische rating der sich
bringen jeweils wenn man geld gehalten
gewesen zu glauben und das ist dann
zunehmend wenig
in dem gebiet um und alle diese dinge
spiegelten sich in der kunst eben nach
89 und in dieser zeit bevor sie sich
dann später internationalen einflüssen
so viel mehr geöffnet hat und sie sind
in diesen in diesen turbulenzen in
dieser in diesem rasenden prozess drin
denn china gemacht hat habe ich den
eindruck sehr stolz durch diese dieser
jahrzehnte gegangen und das bringt uns
ein bisschen auf ihre strategie oder
ihre mission wie sie sich in diesem
prozess drin in ihrer strategie des
sammelns definieren
zunächst habe ich gesagt wird sowie das
alle tun
man kauft aus einem gefällt und bald bei
der suche nach dem was mir gefallen
könnte mir gefiel zuvor schon damit habe
ich mich ausgiebig seit meiner
studentenzeit beschäftigt die
fotofreunde gegenwartskunst
ich konnte aber zunächst nichts finden
was ist auch der grund warum die in den
90er jahren nicht gesamtnote davon gab
es eigentlich noch nichts die kunst
kommt er der iwa tief daher relativ von
der westkunst und erst so gegen ende der
80er jahre haben die künstler zwei
eigene sprache gefunden
daneben habe ich mal für mich mich
umgesehen und dabei habe ich dann
festgestellt dass niemand weder in die
vita und noch institution chinesische
kunst sammelt auch nur den geringsten
sieht es systematisch sammelten
da schieben wir unsere merkwürdigen
größten kulturellen raum der welt
niemand der sich darum kümmert was die
gegenwart künstler zur chinesischen
kultur gegenwartskultur beitragen und so
habe ich mich dann entschieden das zu
tun was eben eine nationale institution
eigentlich hätte tun sollen aber nie
getan hat nämlich 1 1
spiegel der gegenwartskunst produktion
gewissermaßen bereitzustellen
das heißt sie haben nicht mehr sie haben
ihren eigenen geschmack zurückgestellt
und begonnen
eine art enzyklopädisches system
aufzubauen genommen und das ziel in eine
in eine bresche zu springen in ein
vakuum zu füllen zu zu beginn und
gleichzeitig passiert eben eine art von
öffentlicher wahrnehmung trotzdem diese
verzeihen sie mit dem begriff des import
export systems beginnt zu spielen und
ist das nicht an ein bisschen auch so
gewesen dass nicht nur der sammler in
ihnen angesprochen was sondern auch
unternehmer oder manager gesagt ich habe
ein erstes joint venture zwischen ein
technisches zwischen china und der
schweiz lebt kann man auch das kulturell
auf dieser ebene oder in dieser hat von
strategie heben als das ist eine schöne
betrachtungsweise hatte ich mich jetzt
sofort anschließen es war eigentlich
schon diese wie soll ich sagen diese
diese diese eigenart treten der
kunstszene dass ich so was nicht gibt
das musste man zunächst feststellen und
dann habe ich einfach die konsequenz
daraus gezogen aus so sind buch hat sich
das ann gelassen und ich habe dann
gesehen dass das eine doch recht große
mission ist sich mit der selbst angelegt
habe das ganze spektrum des
kunstschaffens abbilden zu machen über
alle medien ich muss ja dann auch zurück
sammeln in die anfänge ebenso 79 und ja
das hat mich sehr viel energie gekostet
das war ja auch lediglich meine passion
ich habe sie auch noch einen broterwerb
aber das muss man sich als statistisch
mal vorstellen
ich weiß auch nicht wie viele tausende
besucher wie viele runden wie viele
künstler
mit denen sie sich auseinander gesetzt
haben dh es ist das kann ja nicht nur
eine art von auftrag sein etwas zu
erfüllen was sonst niemand macht da muss
doch irgendwo eine eine flamme lothar
die die sehr irrational vielleicht sogar
im rückblick scheint es mir auch so und
ich kann es mit kaum mehr erklären woher
der in der gegend das eigentlich zu tun
weil ja gesehen nicht organisiert war
man kommt auch nicht in eine galerie
gehen und sich etwas von der wand kaufen
es gab keinen überblick ich habe dazu
einen kunstpreis damals geschaffen um
apple material in die hand zu bekommen
und ja es war eigentlich ein ziemlich
umfängliches dingen dass ich da frauen
nachts und an den wochenenden
losgetreten habe der alltag in china war
ja vorher auch auf der botschaft wie
zuvor in geschäften sehr fordernd und
man hat eigentlich morgen zum sex
begonnen und irgendwie nacht zum 19 hat
man die arbeit abgeschlossen und dann
ging ich einen stuhl den künstler und
sie haben dann diese kunst auch in der
schweizer botschaft ausgestellt habe ich
gemacht ich wollte ja auch testen wie
die finessen funktionären und denen ich
sehe viele zu gast hatte auf diese kunst
reagieren und das war schon sehr
interessant sie hatten im grunde keine
kenntnis von diesem phänomen das sich
auch zunächst im untergrund abgespielt
hatte und so langsam an die oberfläche
draht und sie fanden auch kaum den
zugang es gab eine kleine minderheit die
mit großem interesse noch mehr sehen
wollte es gab aber eine größere mehrheit
die das dann ignoriert hat nach einem
kurzen augenschein und dann gab's auch
diejenigen die sagten
sie sind doch ein großer freund chinas
warum zeigen sich in einem derart
unvorteilhaften licht und ich musste
lange weiß sagen das bin nicht ich das
sind ihre künstler die diese realität so
wahrnehmen und dann war das gespräch
damit beendet eigentlich wäre das ja
dann erst interessant und gut es gab
dann sagen wir mit den nicht
interessiert nichts wie raus nicht mehr
sehr viel mehr auszutauschen was die
kunst an jetzt sie haben das ja auch
schon angetönt wie diese dieser
kunstmarkt regelrecht explodiert ist
also grundsätzlich auf der welt zur
jahrtausendwende international oder
global aber insbesondere natürlich auch
die chinesische gegenwartskunst und da
waren sie ja mittendrin oder sie haben
dass er überhaupt wie sie auch zu
erzählen sondern sagen losgetreten fast
ich habe mir das leben auch selbst
schwer gemacht eben in der frühen zeit
der 90er jahre hat man über diese
kleinen beträge gesprochen kreis weise
kleinen und die künstler hatten keine
klare vorstellung von wetten sie hatten
manchmal kaum eine substanz ihre
forderung oder völlig abwegige hohe
preise im kopf und man musste dann
wieder etwas realitätsnähe schaffen was
den internationalen kunstmarkt
anbetrifft und daraus hat sich dann aber
mit dem einsetzenden interesse des
internationalen marktes
der war früher als die chinesische
nachfrage mit in diesem moment vor allem
nach venedig hat sich dann eben dieser
preisboom ereignet und er wurde dann
befeuert durch das eintreten auch der
chinesischen zahlen wollten nach den
jahren 2002 muss man sich das vorstellen
als sie waren mit hans seemann in
venedig und haben
das super was was wir was wir geschaffen
haben und gleichzeitig haben sie gemerkt
werden wir haben es nicht mehr im griff
was da eigentlich jetzt losgeht
das kann man vielleicht so sehen also es
kann eigentlich nur darauf an und ich
freue mich über ihren früheren kommentar
es scheint dass ich das erreicht habe
dass eben die leute erstmals diese
chinesische kunst wahrnehmen
es gab sich zwar schon vorher statisch
kleinen ausstellungen auch in europa
aber kann sie so nicht nur logisch fast
motiviert und nur für eine minderheit in
china freaks setra gingen sie anschauen
und das war das erste mal dass ein
breites internationales publikum nicht
anders konnte als eben diese kunst zur
kenntnis zu nehmen weil sie durch das
abo gehen mussten sie muss man diesen
arbeiten vorbeigehen und ja da haben wir
uns einfach gefreut dass sie dieses
interesse auslöst ich habe in keiner
weise an den markt gebracht oder was da
was ich da im markt geben als folge
davon abbilden würde und dann eben diese
art von von rakete ökonomisch nach der
jahrtausendwende
ich habe gelesen dass leben heute mehr
dollar milliardäre in peking als in new
york und also das heißt alle diese neuen
reichen chinesen haben dann auch
begonnen ihre eigene kunst zu entdecken
und zu sammeln
nein das kann man nicht so sehen es gab
eine hand funktioniert rené sicher sein
und die ganz reichen chinesen die haben
sich zwar der europäischen kunst
zugewendet
aber die haben gekämpft und kaufen auch
regte er impressionisten die moderne
also war ein monat steht höchsten
höchstkurs anfang auch dann das so
aber die haben sich nicht unbedingt bei
zeitgenossen chinesin kunstgemeinde das
war eine etwas andere schicht auch reich
geworden aber neugieriger
die hat chinesische gegenwartskunst zu
kaufen begonnen und diese gruppe wendet
sich aber heute immer mehr der
internationalen gegenwartskunst zu das
ist so interessant wie sie sich lange
nur mit chinesischer kunst einigermaßen
sicher fühlten und sie jetzt so weit
sind internationale kunst teils auf
kosten der chinesischen gegenwartskunst
zu sagen und gut das ist natürlich mit
ein thema der globalisierung auch da
werde noch zu sprechen da kommen aber
was muss interessieren würde wäre zu
sagen wenn sich jetzt eine generation
von vermögen chinesen jüngeren chinesen
für globale kunst interessieren dann
interessieren sich automatisch auch für
die globalisierte chinesische kunst ist
sehr hoch im ranking und sind sie dann
vielleicht manchmal ein bisschen
enttäuscht statt auf möchte ich ein
bisschen hinaus wenn sie sehen dass das
was sie in ihre integrität ischen
mission oder das was sie auch als
dokument bezeichnen also einen blog
herzustellen damit nicht etwas vergessen
geht was sonst vergessen gegangen wäre
dass sie das aufgebaut haben und
plötzlich überrennt eigentlich die
ökonomische welle dieses dieses motiv in
dem es einfach gute kapitalanlagen
geworden sind das hat mich nicht
wirklich aber doch etwas beeinträchtigt
im sommer
ich habe natürlich alle diese künstler
die nach also teuer wurden schon in
meiner sammlung
natürlich hätte ich noch einige arbeiten
hin zu kaufen können
aber viele von diesen künstlern machen
eigentlich mehr das gleiche dann gibt es
keinen anlass
neuere arbeiten in meine sammlung
aufzunehmen und damit haben sie es mir
dann doch wieder etwas vereinfacht den
entwicklungen folgen zu können weil das
dann eher die jüngeren künstler sind
gehe ich mir das noch leisten kommt also
das würde bedeuten dass man mehr vom
gleichen das natürlich schon eine art
von der kunstmarkt egon zu spielen und
das dann wie soll man dem sagen das
viele geld das plötzlich auch
internationaler kunst nicht unbedingt
zuträglich war das ist schon so die
künstler hatten nachdem die formel 1
gestanden
was das wirtschaftliche und betrifft in
ihrem leben hatten plötzlich enormen
zulauf haben als den studios hat
ausverkauft und hatten plötzlich zum
teil hunderttausende von dollars die sie
für ein bild bekommen dann muss man
schon einen festen charakter haben um
der versuchung zu widerstehen
man kommt als den nichts man hat sich
nie etwas leisten können und hier macht
man nochmal dasselbe problem könnten ja
selbständiger beträge wer würde da schon
widerstehen auch im westen und in dem
sinne sind viele künstler eben diese
tendenz gefolgt aber natürlich gab es
immer auch die anderen die sich in
keiner weise beeinflussen liess ist
denke das ist etwas was im film sondern
von michael schindhelm ihr sehr
geblieben ist ja geblieben sind die
statements der künstler die die
kulturrevolution als tragendes moment in
ihrer biografie haben also geboren
irgendwie vor den 60er jahren und wo man
auch spürt dass die frage des
leidensdrucks eine eine prägende ist und
dass die frage der offenheit der
kulturellen bildung auch ein thema ist
da möchten wir eines oder zwei stellen
daraus uns anschauen
[Musik]
die kontodaten
slogans
[Musik]
eine eine für mich sehr berührende
sequenz im film und auch melancholisch
dh wo man herkommt diese herkunft ist
hochproblematisch und wenn man sich
nicht interessiert für diese herkunft
dann weiß man nichts über sich selbst
und dass wir heute in einer gesellschaft
sind sie sehr weit davon weg ist und
dass eine art von unwissen bei uns im
westen aber selbst in china
offensichtlich so ist das eine jüngere
generation von künstler sich diese
hintergründe gar nicht mehr vorstellen
kann
das ist richtig das hängt mit der
kommunikation mit den regeln zur
kommunikation der partei zusammen die
große teile der chinesischen jüngsten
geschichte zum tabu erklärt und damit
wird darüber nicht gesprochen also
darüber keine kunst gemacht es wird
nicht diskutiert und das wird auch sehr
weit zu einer art amnesie zum beispiel
89 das ist für mich sehr interessant zu
sehen dass die ganz jungen chinesen
denen sagt das nichts
sie haben sich kein bild je machen
können von den abläufen damals von den
themen damals und hinten diese hecke
technisch existiert was nicht
und in dem sinne ist eigentlich die
propaganda sehr effizient
und die wie sie sagen die die art von
ökonomisierung wenn wir immer noch da
sind das eigentlich auf der einen seite
das eigene gewissen das wissen und
gewissen und auf der anderen seite das
geld und sie sind der vermittler der der
mensch der diese prozesse hautnah
miterlebt hat aber auch initiiert hat
wie gehen sie dann als soll ich sagen
manchmal jedoch jeder rockstar hat einen
manager der ihm sagt so bleiben wir
haben teppich ist das ein wichtiger teil
ihrer arbeit gewesen auch zu dämpfen
prozesse für reiche herren ihren fonds
zu erklären
ich bin eigentlich zu einer art
consultant für die künstler geworden
die dieser plötzliche nachfrage mit
unverständnis gegenüber standen die
nicht wussten was sollten sie tun ich
erinnere mich an eine erste aktion die
eigene der beiden großen aktions
veräußert auf der welt erstmals plante
für chinesische gegenwartskunst und
vielleicht zehn oder mehr könnte hat
mich dann angesprochen und gesagt da
will diese option also eine arbeit von
mirja k nicht eine arbeit
wahrscheinlich ihn gebe kommt die je zu
mir zurück ich gehe man nicht davon aus
dass ich geld sie in welt und wer ist
das überhaupt also das war der
wissensstand und ja viele wollten
einfach wissen was muss soll ich denn
tun aus künstler einmal
die strategie oder wie die arbeiten
irgendwie zudem zwei eine publikum
kommen aber auch einen künstlerischen
diskurs den sie eigentlich kann je
führen kommt und es war für die total
ungewohnt ihre arbeit und die trinken zu
verbalisieren in einem gespräch wie wir
es hatten sie und ich und das war für
viele ein einmaliges erlebnis und das
wollten sie eigentlich weiter pflegen
und
haben sie den selbstbewussten also
meinen immer wieder in ihren
strategischen denken die in diesem in
diesem bewusstsein einer
enzyklopädischen last die auf ihnen
liegt zu sagen ich muss steuern also ich
muss ich muss steuern aber ich bin ja
auch keine institution ich bin nicht
china ich bin musiker aus der schweiz
gut man macht das eben so gut wie man es
kann
und natürlich kann man eine solche
einzig op tische sammlung nie
vollständig haben
man versucht die richtungen festzulegen
das musste ich tun sagen wir oft auch
durch ein netzwerk das ich mir langsam
bildete durch viele gespräche und was
mir auch sehr hoch waren meine
kenntnisse dritten westlichen kunst
westlichen gegenwartskunst
dann kann man auch besser einordnen
welche ausdrucksformen oder der
chinesischen gegenwartskunst man
gegenübersteht und welche zum beispiel
wirklich innovativ sind oder welche
vielleicht einfach ein abklatsch oder
des kunstkurses aus dem westen sind sich
lange vorher ereignet hat und ja das
sind so fragen den ich so gut wie
möglich einfach begegnete aber haben sie
das bedürfnis wenn sie sagen dass sie
diese last ist eigentlich ein bisschen
zu groß 1,4 milliarden chinesen und ich
habe eine eine berufung
und ich weiß das ja die meisten oder die
wichtigsten gegenwartskunst muss er in
diesen china mittlerweile gibt dass das
schiff auch private initiativen sind
dass sie oft auch marktwirtschaftliche
eine thematische oder sponsoren
initiativen sind und dass sie dann sehen
dass waren sie ja auch nicht sie war
nicht eine die bank sondern sie waren
immer noch jemand der dieses dokument
schaffen wollte mit einer idee und dass
sie dieses kulturelle erbe das ohne sie
vielleicht gar nie existiert hätte
dass sie das tragen müssen und haben sie
nie staatliche hilfe gesucht also sagen
dass da brauche ich jetzt china nein das
wäre im grunde kontraproduktiv gewesen
weil daraus erklärt sich auch warum es
keine solche sammlung in china gibt weil
sie eben nicht diese prämierten bild
entsprechend dass die staatlichen
institutionen von china zeichnen müssen
das weiß im inland sei es im ausland
damit eben können sie sehr viel von
dieser gegenwart kunst weder aufstellen
noch sammeln
und gerade diese lücken größer als die
soll sagen dass jenige dass diese
institutionen über halb sammlung kommt
und sie kommen eigentlich ein ganz
schmales segment dagegen wort kommt
kunstproduktion zusammen nämlich so was
wie so akademische malerei nennen das
konnten sie auch privat ihnen verwehrt
also konnte ich auch keine hilfe aus
dieser richtung erwarten und ich habe
aber auch deshalb diesen kunstpreis
geschaffen das war 1997 wo ich dann sehr
wichtige internationale kuratoren und
auch chinesische kuratoren zusammen
bringen konnte die das material
beurteilten und gehe dann sich auf einen
preisträger jeweils einigten und das
waren für mich immer hoch interessante
diskussion indem wir dann auch natürlich
im sommer zu gute kamen
also das heißt dieses netzwerk das sie
sich aufgebaut hatten hat sie
komplettiert und sie sind ja aber
komplettieren sich schon fast selber
also das ist sehr schwer einen begriff
für sie zu finden und eine
berufsbezeichnung also noch einmal sind
manager gewesen sie sind unternehmer bis
heute diplomat und eben sammlung aber
das haben wir jetzt auch eben
vermittlung mit 10 und
coach wie sie das erklärt haben und
damit hätten sie ja quasi in dieser
dreifaltigkeit der us-diplomaten das
unternehmen als also business und
business politik und kunst ja auch
diesen prozess von china weg von der
werkbank der welt von von der billig
industrie hin zur smart so seit ich war
ja kunst und kreativwirtschaft ein
wichtiger faktor ist ja vielleicht so
eine schule für gehabt um dazu sagen sie
eben noch einmal erstes joint venture
hat geklappt das zweite ist doch auch
prima aber sie haben etwas wichtiges
gesagt mir war neben diese drei zugänge
zurück in essen realitäten und noten
wichtig und oder der eine zugang hat
jeweils den anderen eben leverage auf
diese weise konnte ich mich ein ganz
anderes bild verschaffen als diejenigen
die in einer oder vielleicht einfach in
zwei disziplinen sich wieder genähert
haben und das wiederum hat meinen
sammeln oder sehr gut informiert dass
die kenntnisse die ich als rechtmässigen
gesellschaft hatte aber die diejenigen
die sich nur der kunst annehmen frau
wenn sie von außen kommen eure
diejenigen die sich nur beim business
oder nur der politik annehmen
die können das gar nicht integrieren in
der weise wie ich das konnte und das
haben wir beim zusammen und unheimlich
geholfen aber auch wenn ich sie richtig
verstehe dass sie die diese kreis verden
auch trennen voneinander
ich wollte sie nicht unbedingt brenne
ich wollte sie zumindest in meinem kopf
zusammenführen hatte weil eben daraus
ein wissen entsteht dass man an dass
sich nicht aneignen konnten aber jetzt
der unternehmer in ihnen hätte er sagen
können und das auch noch und verkaufs
wieder oder weil darin ist die
erstwähler direkt liegt aber stehe
mein ziel war eigentlich wie ich diesen
neuen focus also dieses einzigartige
sammlung definiert habe eine sammlung
zusammen zu stellen und sie dann china
zu übergeben damit die chinesin
überhaupt ist
ihre eigene gegenwartskunst zu gesicht
bekommen
das habe ich nie eine finanzielle
überlegung angestellt was daraus werden
könnte
einzig vielleicht kann ich mir das
leisten weil mein einkommen und haben
auch nicht gerade jetzt besonders und
also indem sie habe ich nie eine
investment überlegung angestellt weil
sie wie zugute gekommen wäre
da kommen wir jetzt langsam auch auf die
auf den status quo auf das heute ihre
sammlung zu sprechen
ihre sammlung wird in anderthalb jahren
2009/10 in einem großen museum in
hongkong zu sehen sein sie haben einen
großen teilen worden ich kenne die
zahlen nicht ganz genau was er geschafft
etwa 1500 arbeiten werden in kürze den
chinesen zugänglich sein und werden
öffentlich sein in einem großen museum
und das heißt auch hier ist wie ein
prozess dieser globalisierung eigentlich
kommt zu einem abschluss also der kreis
in einem gewissen sinn schließt sich
nicht ganz genau weil es wir sind in
hongkong nicht wirklich in festlandchina
aber das würde mich jetzt als letztes
kapitel unseres gesprächs interessieren
diese identitätsfindung sie haben gesagt
dass in den 70er jahren weitere von
bewegung politik dann in den 80ern noch
sehr epigonal der westen reproduziert
wurde in der chinesischen
gegenwartskunst es dann mitte der 80er
und 90er kam diese eigene haltung mit
eigenen themen und dass die
globalisierung dann um die
jahrtausendwende begonnen hat wird sich
zu spielen
aber wie global muss man sich und weil
sie eben beide kunstwelten kennen wie
global ist diese globalisierte kunst
wird eigentlich die entwicklung ist
nicht unbedingt geradlinig verlaufen bis
heute also zunächst eben regionale kunst
die künstler mussten sich überhaupt
einen misston verschaffen sie waren
total isoliert gewesen von der außenwelt
das haben sie dann über die 80er jahre
geleistet
und so in den 90er jahren kann dann
information als dem westen nicht mehr
nur zufällig sondern auch systematisch
und sie haben dann auch ein leben
geführt die künstler aus demjenigen
begriffe messen immer ähnlicher geworden
ist in dem sie auch zugang zum internet
hatten auch zugang zu katalog und
magazin selbst sogar dreisten eingeladen
wurden und in dem sinne hatten sie
plötzlich kenntnisse vom globalen
kunstdiskurs und das ist damit die
kunstproduktion eingeschlossen und es
hat dann eigentlich wie eine zweiteilung
sich herausgebildet die einen die dann
zum schluss kamen also mit mit der
chinese mit china haben wir nichts am
hut wir wollen großartige künstler unter
guten künstlern seien und wir möchten
nicht unseres chinesischen passes wegen
ausgestellt werden und die andern die
dann sagten er eigentlich müssen wir um
auch in der globalen kunstproduktion zu
bestehen
im grunde bei differenz arbeiten das
heißt unsere eigenen wurzeln sind
vielleicht eine ressource auf die die
anderen ja keinen zugriff haben
und so hat sich 1 1 1 toren eine wende
zur tradition eigentlich auch
abgezeichnet für ein anderes feld
und so hat es ja eine gewisse eine
zweiteilung gegeben aber beide wollen ja
in diesem globalen kunstdiskurs jetzt
wahrgenommen werden und sich eine
position erarbeiten und die sammlung
zeigt eigentlich diese tendenzen sehr
gut auf und hongkong wo die sammlung
jahr hingeht ist china aber ist nicht
dasselbe wie mainland china hatte eine
ganz ganz kleine kunstszene
es gab kaum interesse für
gegenwartskunst oder überhaupt für
visuelle kunst in hongkong bis auf eine
zuneigung zu was sie zeitgenössische
tuschemalerei nennen
das hat sich so also eine hongkong
hongkong eine eigene disziplin
herausgebildet und jetzt mit dieser
institution und mit dass es mit dieser
sammlung auch mit der art basel
auch mit dem zugang jetzt alle zufluss
großer karrieren in hongkong hat sich da
jetzt so ein sams bedeutete hat
ausgebildet und da hinein kommt dass
dieses neue museum und in dem sinne wird
auch com denke ich führend werden was ja
die die kunst als diese vor allem
ostasiatischen raum anbetrifft oder ist
es bereits jetzt wenn wir den einzigen
christen beiseitelassen mal ganz kurz
und sagen für welche dieser beiden
fraktionen schlägt ihr herz
ich persönlich bin sehr interessiert an
diesem törn zu tradition
[Musik]
warum ist das so ich denke wir sind so
bei nord soft power diskussion angelangt
das ist ja ein großes manko von china im
globalen auftritt wenn wir an amerika
denken an den american dream und die
wasser schmeckt es etwa die haben
eigentlich die welt der oper tut sich
sehr schwer ist jetzt weltmacht tritt
jetzt möglicherweise die nachfolge der
usa an
aber hat eigentlich keine projektion die
die welt wirklich erreicht bis auf
chinesische küche akupunktur kennt aber
das hat keine strahlkraft die mieter
amerikanischen gleich bar ist und da
suchen jetzt die chinesen ich denke zu
recht in ihrer eigenen kultur und in
ihrer tradition was könnte man denn an
diesen wert wieder zutage fördern
was kann bestehen neben einer westlichen
wertegemeinschaft also was könnte china
hier
neues ansehnliches eindrückliches in
diesem diskurs einbringen
und da denke ich ist diese suche in den
wurzeln sehr interessant zu verfolgen
und könnte es dann auch irgendeine art
von pragmatismus spielen dass wenn china
sich wirklich auch identifizieren muss
als wenn china 2050 wirklich alle
industrienationen überholt hat und wenn
man diese art von machtkonzentration und
präsenz international zu spielen beginnt
und wir haben aufgehört haben das jetzt
so etwas was ja auch in der neuen
zürcher zeitung als als paradox
beschrieben wurde dass der chinesische
staats und parteichef für die öffnung
ist und also für eröffnung ist für
freihandel und für globalisierung und
amerika ein tag später drei tage später
mit rang wegen die die die schotten
dicht macht dass in dieser situation die
in china eine art von take over auch in
der inter massenkultur wie sieht das ein
bisschen bestimmt hatten und von amerika
haben hier das zwanzigste jahrhundert
erlebt und sie haben uns den jazz
gebraucht trocken dort gebracht in
underground gedacht gebracht cool ness
gebracht was wir hörten uns china
bringen
china hat natürlich weil mir zu haben
die visuelle welt und das design denken
einen fast unermesslichen schatz und
formen zeichnung an ausdrucksformen oder
die sich in der tradition zum teil über
die jahrtausende herausgebildet haben
die wir eigentlich nicht kennen und wenn
man die fortschreibt in eine
unzeitgemäße fordern würde dann könnte
es durchaus dass andere seien aber von
von gleiche anziehungskraft
aber das muss noch geschehen was muss
noch geschehen und dass das ja wie wenn
man den langen bogen spannt eine art von
exam schöner kontinuität über tausende
von jahren dann gibt es dieses der
kulturrevolution und das was nachher kam
dieses schütteln über mehrere
jahrzehnte das dass sich das auch wieder
quasi ihn beruhigt und und in eine
sphäre geht aber was mich interessiert
in diesem schütteln sind wir ja immer
noch drin und am schluss des films
michael schindhelm kommt eivor reif und
dem sie gesprochen hatten vermutlich der
bekannteste künstler und und nach einer
der wirklich kritischen künstler aus
china der so eine kleine geschichte
erzählt die wir uns schnell anschauen
müssen so etwas wollte ihnen einmal
weiter mit haken und dazu muss man ihn
kennen erwägt sowie ein bestätigen wäre
aber er ist natürlich ein zyniker und im
gespräch auch für humor und er will
damit sagen die chinesische regierung
weiß damit nicht umzugehen
sie schenkt dem eigentlich keine
bedeutung das ist seine persönliche
meinung
ich bin nicht ganz dieser meinung ich
denke zwar nicht die chinesische
regierung aber viele andere haben schon
längst den wert einer solchen sammlung
kommt sie wissen gegen wann werden die
kinder von heute ihre eltern freut muss
haben denn unsere künstler gemacht in
den 80er und 90er jahren 2000 jahren
und da werden sie dann die antwort
findet nicht im system sagt also dort wo
sie wohnen aber wenn jetzt dieser kreis
geschlossen hat bald ist mir etwas
geblieben also ihre eigentlich ihre
aufgabe ist erfüllt das eine dass das
würde mich interessieren was kommt und
das andere ist gibt es eigentlich einen
chinesischen musik also von dem sie
wissen dass da etwas weitergeht oder
einen chinesen
also es gibt natürlich heute einige
finessen
gewesen die diese ambition haben aber
das material ist eigentlich nicht mehr
auffindbar wenn wir an die 80er 90er
jahre denken und sie haben zu spät
begonnen und sie haben wie das auf der
ganzen welt üblich ist jedenfalls wenn
private das in angriff nehmen sie haben
sich auf das zweidimensionale beschränkt
sie haben malerei gesang und vielleicht
extensiv aber sie haben zunächst der
fotografie der installationskunst
performance keine beachtung geschenkt
und in dem sinne weil ich das alles von
beginn weg gemacht habe könne sie es
nicht nachvollziehen aber die
institutionen müssten jetzt eigentlich
irgendwann übernehmen und sie können
ganz neue von vorne beginnen jetzt ich
konnte und nach jährige nun nach lust
und laune
es ist so herzlich in herzlichen dank
für das gespräch
nächste woche reist meine kollegin
barbara bleisch zwar nicht nach china
aber in die zukunft sie spricht mit dem
weltberühmten historiker rio war ferrari
über die menschheit von morgen die vor
allem eines nicht mehr will mensch sein
da kann man gespannt sein und jetzt
gleich in der sternstunde musik zeigen
wir einen dokumentarfilm über den
flamboyanten dirigenten teodor
currentzis
[Musik]